шановні студенти учасники Кубку світу з
єдиноборств пишаюся тим що ви будете
представляти нашу державу та
університети України на міжнародних
студентських змаганнях які відбудуться у
вересні в Туреччині в місті Samsung
у змаганнях братимуть участь близько
тисячі двохсот студентів які
представлятимуть 344 університети світу
із 50 країн Україна буде представлена
110 студентами спортсменами із 50
університетів які будуть змагатися у
шести видах спорту бокс карате
тайландський бокс муатай боротьба самбо
боротьба вільна боротьба Грека римська
та ушу
ви вирушаєте на ці змагання вони простий
для країни час але Ми впевнені що як
завжди наші спортивні студенство гідно
буде представлено на Кубку світу серед
студентів з єдиноборств
бажаю вам успіхів на змаганнях яскравих
перемог та приємно спілкування з
студентами інших країн світу Разом до
перемоги ми сильні ми Україна З повагою
до вас Слава Україні